before he underwent his transformation
Steve Rogers was sick weak frail useless
don't you know when to quit nerd I can
do this all day
ish oh [ __ ] Wow world's most successful
biological sperm
it's going to hurt through the injection
of Super Soldier Serum
the world's perfect so who also happens
to be gay
wait what yes like super gay no no I'm
not gay
yes he is no I was the Wiener no I don't
his desire for it is insatiable dad
seems bordering on inappropriate for a
family film too bad looking gauged isn't
even the updated wardrobe significantly
Gare our market research tells us that
America craves more queer super well who
is doing your market research
HuffPo and feminist frequency there's
your problem
there they're not even joined cap on his
latest adventures in nightclubbing love
this place
yeah super gay hash tagging black lives
matter his conquest of the Folsom Street
Fair
and AIDS this summer Captain America is
the social justice soldier
it's time to make Captain America gay
that's happening that's the new movement
hashtag give Captain America a boyfriend
make him gay you may be wondering where
did this come from it was planted out
there as an idea by a liberal writer for
the New York Times but this is not at
all a mainstream uprising a populist
desire for superheroes to now be light
in the loafers it is entirely driven by
hashtags on Twitter from social justice
warriors hell-bent on appropriating
long-standing already straight
characters now before I continue I have
to issue the prerequisite I'm not
homophobic but I have a lot of gay
friends gay people are the best among us
they never do anything wrong we
shouldn't criticize them so that you can
save yourself some comments and let's
move on with reality the back last year
isn't about people being upset over gay
characters and superhero films
the problem is with being creatively
lazy and trying to ride on the coattails
of already straight characters and even
though you may not like to hear this
gays are already incredibly
over-represented in the entertainment
industry anyway it's true despite making
up only 3% of the population over 15% of
films feature gay characters coming from
the big studios it's as high as 18k
people are so overly represented in the
entertainment industry that the
perception of Americans most Americans
is that over 23% of the population is
gay again the problem people have is not
with any gay superhero you know how I
know there are plenty of gay superheroes
out there including in the Marvel
Universe why don't they take their
chance isn't Bank on a film with one of
these guys maybe Studios don't want to
bank on those because what you push as
heteronormativity is actually just a
response to market forces with 97 to 98%
of the population being straight and
historically they don't tend to go out
in record numbers for leading men sure
critics love them but movie goers don't
that's why angley wins an award for gay
cowboys despite the fact that nobody
liked the film and he's never made a
good film since then now I like
Crouching Tiger incorrect now is that
just because everybody out there hates
gay people no of course not the truth is
that this wouldn't change all that much
in the story arc outside of the sexual
tension and if people are being
with themselves most straight people get
a little uncomfortable watching gay sex
scenes is it because they hate gay
people no I was incredibly uncomfortable
seeing Kathy Bates naked and about
Schmidt for context two naked gay dudes
is more unattractive to me as a straight
man the point is this isn't simply about
love versus hate you've got plenty of
liberal progressive Americans out there
who also don't want to see Captain
America being appropriated into a gay
character that norian tation
appropriation could go both ways I wish
I knew how to quit you why don't you why
don't you just let me be huh like in
sunsets and Leon's getting larger I
don't see a case I have a case if you
don't want it for personal reasons
thank you that's correct I don't why
could be greased lightning
that she learn warrant I'm back wide in
bridges he burned or the way that she
down
the story never ends
hey if you like this video subscribe by
clicking on Captain America in front of
the gay flag because rainbows are
apparently gay now or watch one of these
videos playing in a box next to it it's
all for free
I leave the choice to you